first down play fake to the that's the
famed voice the Dallas Cowboys Brad sham
with Jason Witten back in the National
Football League back with the Dallas
Cowboys back in the endzone fittingly
enough last time he caught a touchdown
pass was on the 10th of December 2017
against the Giants he likes to do it
against the Giants and he's here on
behalf of our good friends at courtyard
here on the Rich Eisen show Jason Witten
how are you Jason I'm doing well it's
great to be on with it what was that
like being back in the end zone in an
NFL game what was that like for you oh I
felt great you know I think the biggest
thing is you know when you make a
decision to come out of retirement and
you start the work and certainly it
takes a lot of work to get back out
there you know you think about those
moments playing the New York Giants in
week one and you know helping your team
win you know by getting in the end zone
so it was a special moment and you know
you try to process it the long season
you got to move on but that's one that
we'll remember for a long time where's
that ball right now where is it I think
the equipment managers have it I hope
anyway you know I just kind of gave it
to the official it's kind of the overall
I have act like you've been there before
you know about that Ridge I do it's
interesting that 41 oh yes I do act like
I've been there before
every single time unfortunately every
single 40 looks like the one from before
Jason that's my problem so now that
you're back in it and and you see what
Jack looked like last time you saw DAC
he was just a mere rookie and we were
going through that old business of Romo
or ham and ham and Romo how different is
he now Jason well I just I mean I think
he's playing I mean look what he did on
Sunday I mean just plan at that high
high level you know and I think a lot of
times when you start evaluating or we
talk about young quarterbacks you know
we're like what's the one thing did they
approve on you know they're taking that
next step you know that that really
entails a lot of different things and I
think for dak it's like he's done all of
them you know I mean line one for now my
think is he has the respect of everybody
in that locker
he's a true leader and that's not the
case and those there's 52 other guys and
certainly support staff and coaches that
would run through a law firm and that's
important especially at the quarterback
position and he kept can he really
defines what you want out of QB one
hard-working dependable great leader and
is comfortable with this system he's in
command his ability to get to all the
different checks is velocity of throws
you know being aligned with Keller more
the new young coordinator I just think
he's done all that at a high level and
that's why he's had that success and
week one have you ever had a coordinator
younger than you is this a first for you
Jason this is the first and first former
teammate of mine that the coordinator
right that's right - so what has he
brought to the equation that's never
been brought to the equation in all your
time in Dallas Jason well I think you
know Sunday what you saw was a lot of
pre snap shifts in motions you know I
mean it's the first thing you think of
is look what the Rams have done in the
last two years with Shawne McVeigh and
you know I feel like it comes off of
that tree branch so to speak of you know
kind of try to confuse the defense with
some stuff with tempo and pre-snap - and
not allow them to get to the perfect
look and that's easier said than done
you know I mean and Kellen has done a
good job of simplifying all that and
then you know we're built to give Zeke
the ball you know he's going to get his
carries and we're gonna kind of grind
out a lot of those gains with our
Russian attack behind our great
offensive line but I just think Sunday
was a it was an attacking offense a
play-action game down the middle there's
a lot of weapons and I give credit
Keller a lot of credit to stay in that
attack mindset and really try to attack
the game vertically something that it
was nice to see in this offense Jason
Witten future hall-of-famer back with
the Cowboys back here on the Rich Eisen
show so your coach is well you've been
around Garrett for a long time and he's
in a walk here after all these years
he's coaching for his gig and I'm
wondering how that changes anything do
you see any difference in all Jason
well no I mean I think look at that
you're right I mean that could be a
difficult situation for a lot of teams
but I've known Jason a long time I mean
he doesn't blink he doesn't get fazed by
those things you know I mean he really
doesn't I mean talking about eliminating
an outside noise I don't know that I
know anybody that does that better than
then than him you know and so if you
think he's going to be fazed by that
it's he's not he's just simply thinks
all right how can this team get better
how can we win and I think he's done a
good job with you know adding Kellen to
the mix and giving him the freedom and
you know Chris was short as a young
coach and what he's done with the
defense and certainly the players
respect him so he's unfazed by it I
think that just comes with his
experience as a player and an assistant
coach and you know being in the Cowboys
organization there as long as he has he
realizes hey there's gonna be a lot of
talk about those things and the ability
to kind of minimize it and not allow
that to affect you easier said and done
I think you've done a great job with it
well you spent a year in the outside
noise so you know everybody thinks he
just stands there and claps you know so
give me an example if you can as to what
he does for you players locker room
either from before your time with the
SPN or now that you can say this is the
reason why we're as good as we are well
I think you know Ryan one for me the one
I look for and head coach is does he
provide perspective can you tell us tire
to the week's game hey here's the
challenges here's what we have to do
tell us that we're gonna win the game
give us the blueprint certainly we got
to go out there and do it and you need
playmakers to do that but let me know
how I'm gonna do it give me some hope as
I get prepared for this week's game of
what that formula looks like you know I
mean I played for poor shells I don't
know that anybody did that better than
helming certainly Bella checks names got
to be mentioned in there but you know
tell us how we're gonna win what that
formula looks like I think Jason does a
good job of identifying that early in
the week you kind of holding your foot
to the fire making shirring making sure
that you do that in the weeks work how
you prepare how you train and then
reminding you you know just kind of all
right guys here we go
bring it back
and then within the game you know I
think that's the misconception right of
the clapper and all that that you
reference I mean he is constantly
talking about situations in the game we
rep those game situations it came up
before the half with nine seconds of our
defense running the sideline defense it
converts when they try to go for the
Hail Mary I mean all those situational
football things that I think really good
head coaches talk about and walk through
I think jason has done a good job of
that and so you know it's a ShowMe game
you got to go win players and coaches
alike and he gets that he's not worried
about that he doesn't he doesn't allow
that to enter his mindset you know he's
a mentally tough guy he really is and
and he's got a lot of trust in his
coaching staff to delegate some of that
and he believes in his players for sure
well and in your tenure with Dallas in a
few minutes I have left with you Jason
Witten of the Dallas Cowboys on occasion
it was a search for a quarterback but
obviously had Romo for all those years
now you got dak sometimes it was who's
the second wide receiver who's the other
person sometimes it was who's that the
other receiver other than you Jason now
it just seems like there is all over the
lot playmakers and now you and that
defense is this the best Dallas Cowboys
team you've ever played on gosh there's
been some good ones over the years you
know oh seven was a good team but you
know I think if you're stacking them up
certainly this is this is as good of a
team it's not the best team that roster
that I played with you know just looking
at that skill set I mean I've had some
great ones you know tio and dad's of
course and a lot of weapons but you know
you see it Mari you see Gallup come on
Cobbs a great pickup he's a pro's Pro
certainly you know this offense goes
through Zeke and and I look at this
defense and the way they play just the
effort that they play with I mean that
Rod Marinelli I mean it's paying off
home the best thing about this group
it's an accountable group it's a
hard-working it's a humble group you
know and you look what they did last
year three and five you know when we
talking about the noise I mean it got
pretty loud there in Dallas
and the ability to kind of step back and
find a way to win the division I think
that can give you a lot of confidence as
a young team and now enter this year so
hopefully that carries over but yeah
it's a good roster that we've had around
here and a great group of guys it makes
it a lot of fun to go into work every
day and and try to get better well we've
been talking about the courtyard the
courtyard contest the Super Bowl contest
in which folks need to talk about their
love of the game and the friends who
have their backs in order to get in the
stadium the night before the Super Bowl
sleep there and wake up there perhaps
maybe to see your Cowboys who's who's
the who's the friend that you put out
there for courtyard for your
relationship Jason well I had all mentor
when I first got here and that was
Emmitt Smith so he's my friend okay uh
you know I don't think I'll ever get to
his yardage I can keep stacking it up
right it's that it's what it is and
great experience by courtyard a Super
Bowl sleepover contest and some of their
friends to get out there and experience
that nothing like it yeah I know we've
been we've been telling people just go
ahead and and send in a photograph and a
way for you to talk about your
friendship and your love of your team
and the love of the football world and
you get to stay maybe in the Super Bowl
of stadium the night before and wake up
and see your Cowboys right Jason that's
exactly right that's all we hoping for I
meant to tell you a rich - yes sir the
great that you had Craig Kilborn back in
there yeah you saw killer here I did and
oak Center in the mid nineties man
nothing like it hey Jason you were you
were getting set to go to Tennessee back
when I started with well before that
were you in high school when I started
were you in high school in 1996 oh yeah
freshman in high school oh my gosh I
feel older now but so you saw Kilbourne
here Kilbourne was amazing wasn't he
Jason always appreciate you being out
there and hopefully this first of many
times I get you back here on the show
you one of my favorites
all right thanks good talking with you
got it that's Jason Witten Cowboys tied
in right here on the Rich Eisen show for
more of the
J'son show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app